so Beto O'Rourke poor fella there was a
time when he was getting a lot of hype
he was considered a real contender but
now he's lost somewhere in the middle of
the pack
with nary a table to stand on and he's
because I think I think mainly because
he's dealing with with probably a fatal
flaw for a Democrat in 2019 and that is
that he's a white male the problem with
being a white male is that number one
white males are toxic scum and should
all dies that's problem number one
number two related to number one is that
if you're a white male then you're
automatically going to be under
suspicion of being unwell
okay so unwellness is is you know a
condition that plagues most white male
so if you are a white male people are
gonna suspect that you lack focus and
which means that if you want to run for
president as a Democrat you're gonna
have to do quite a lot to prove your
innocence to prove that you are in fact
woke that you are not guilty of the
crime of being unwell so it is a guilty
until proven innocent sort of situation
and beto along with his other white male
candidate compatriots has been trying
very hard to quell the suspicions that
he may in fact be unwell and that is why
he went to a group of immigrants
yesterday and trashed America talked
about how bad America is which is a very
woke thing to do but will it pay off and
well we'll get into that just a second
but before we do you know no one really
has the time to go to the post office
you're busy you got stuff to do who's
got time for all the traffic parking
looking all your mail and your packages
into the place it's a real hassle that's
why you need stamps calm one of the most
popular time-saving tools for small
businesses stamps.com eliminates trips
to the post office and it saves you
money with discounts that you can't even
get at the post office
so stamps calm brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office right
to your computer whether you're a small
business sending invoices you're an
online seller shipping out products even
if you're a warehouse
well you yourself are not aware else but
you you know you run a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle
all of that no problem gets through all
the hassle and everything and it just
gets right down to what you need simply
use your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it to
once your mail is ready you just hand it
to your mail carrier or drop it in a
mailbox and it really is that simple
with stamps calm you get five cents off
every first class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail stamps calm is a
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money and that's why over 700
thousand small businesses already use
stamps calm right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in Walsh that's stamps comm enter
Walsh
alright so Beto in pursuit of woke miss
maybe that should be the the you know
sort of pursuit of happiness maybe that
that should be the name of his memoirs
pursuit of locus he went to speak to a
group of immigrants and refugees
yesterday and he said this watch this
country was founded on white supremacy
and every single institution and
structure that we have in our country
still reflects the legacy of slavery and
segregation and Jim Crow and suppression
even in our democracy ok a few things
here first and this is the part I don't
get
if you are if it's true that America is
a racist sexist bigoted hellscape
founded on white supremacy and to this
day institutionally oppresses minorities
a country where the legacy of slavery
still lives on is still alive and well
and affecting minorities even today then
why the hell would you encourage
immigrants to come here and see it seems
like a very cruel and hateful thing to
do I mean wouldn't it be an act of
compassion an act of concern and
sympathy to prevent them from coming
shouldn't you be stationed you yourself
then if you hold this position if
you hold this um you shouldn't you
shouldn't better O'Rourke be standing at
the border yourself saying no don't come
here
save yourself anywhere but here
no but that's not what happens to you
the people that hold this view these are
the same people flinging open the doors
and then saying hey come on in
encouraging people to come it's it's
it's like it's like giving a restaurant
a scathing review on Yelp and then
turning around and recommending the
place to all of your French family and
friends it just it doesn't so if you do
that it means that either your review
was untrue and you really liked the
place more than you said or you hate
your friends and family even more than
you hate the restaurant that you're
trying to inflict that on them so it
just does it doesn't make sense to oh
you know this place is terrible I got
salmonella poisoning and then the next
day hey you know that place I joint down
the street you should really check that
out you'll love it
you're like a biological terrorist in
that case and so it's a similar thing
here you're saying that it's a racist
place it's a harbor and then you're what
what's gonna happen to all these people
that you're encouraging and coming not
only that but you're saying we're
running concentration camps down on the
border and you're still encouraging
people to come what's wrong you you how
evil can you be but it's worse than that
because Democrats will not only
encourage minorities to come here where
they're going to allegedly be oppressed
and discriminated against in locking
guns concentration camps but they'll
even say that America is there you know
is is their hope it's the fulfillment of
a dream errs dream it's their only
chance at a better life etc well fine
but if that's the case then you can't
also say that America is a Handmaid's
Tale it's sort of it's got to be one of
the other you have to choose one
narrative or the other it can't be that
we have to fling open the doors for
immigrants because this country is their
only hope and their only dream but then
also it is a dystopian racist nightmare
you know land of Horrors for minorities
it's just you really got to choose
second thing these white male Democratic
candidates have a problem if it's really
as bad as they say that it's hard to
justify staying in the race at all as a
white male I mean shouldn't I minority
or a woman or both be in charge in that
case of course all the white males in
the race have said oh yeah you know I'll
have a female vice president but that's
even worse because now you're saying
yeah I mean we should definitely have
women in power but they shouldn't be in
charge I mean there's still got to be a
man above the woman just making sure
everything's squared away so yeah we
should definitely we definitely need to
have a woman in the White House but but
no no not in charge I'll hold on a
second I mean these are women we're
talking about here okay
that's what it sounds like when you
start doing oh yeah well we definitely
mean we definitely need to have a woman
in there
no not there not there not sitting
behind the Oval Office but it should
with a smaller desk but still with a
desk it just doesn't it doesn't work
that's the problem you run into and
that's why as a white male you will
always lose the identity politics game
you just you can't it's a lose-lose for
you there's no way to win so you have to
just not play it or completely submit to
it and and withdraw from public life
entirely because you are as I said toxic
scum who should die as a white male and
so am I let's be clear third maybe this
is the most important thing to discuss
is it true is what Beto said true was
America founded on white supremacy well
no of course it wasn't founded on white
supremacy implies that white supremacy
was sort of the point like the founders
were looking primarily to establish a
country where whites would be supreme
where they would be in charge but the
thing is they already had a country like
that the country they broke away from
that was all
the case and so that wasn't the point
America was founded on principles of
liberty and limited government that's
what it was founded on I mean read the
Declaration of Independence were those
principles consistently and fully
applied well no of course they weren't
but those were still the principles is
it true that as Beto says to get the
exact quote every single institution and
structure we have in this country still
reflects the legacy of slavery well no
of course it's not true and if it were
true then what will here's my question
if it's true that America is still
institutionally racist and that the
legacy of slavery lives on so what will
make it so that that isn't true anymore
we'll take more time well it's already
been 150 years since slavery and you're
still saying that the legacy of slavery
is there so apparently time doesn't
matter do we need to have more
minorities in charge well we had a black
president for eight years and that
apparently didn't even make a dent in
institutional racism
we had a black person running the whole
system the whole institution and and but
apparently that so and if you thought
that that meant that institutional
racism was gone well it would seem to me
that that would be a logical conclusion
if a black man can successfully become
the most powerful person in the country
it would seem to indicate that we don't
have a very serious problem with
institutional discrimination against
black men or or or it means that the
institutional discrimination is so
incompetent and ineffective that a black
person can still become the president of
the country either way but see that
would be a that would be a logical
conclusion but but leftist will say oh
no no that's not only will they disagree
with that conclusion but they will heap
scorn on you if you even suggest it oh
you mean that just because we had a
black president there's
not a problem with institutional racism
well yeah I guess I am saying that I
think it probably does mean that that
seems to be a what but no they'll say
it's kind of like when you know leftist
they they make these racism charges and
they accuse everyone of being racist and
everything of being racist and they set
it up so that it is a in accusation that
simply cannot be disproven because any
evidence that would seem to indicate
otherwise
they immediately discard as invalid
without explaining why it is invalid so
they'll say that America is
institutionally racist evidence against
that view would seem to be we had a
black president they say no that doesn't
count I don't know why just doesn't
count it's a similar thing to if you
know it's it's a sort of classic faux
pas that if you're accused of racism
you're not allowed to point out that you
have close friends who are black that's
that's a what we're told is that
actually that makes you even more racist
if you use that as evidence that you're
not racist if you try to say oh I can't
be racist our black friends that's
option well you're even that's even more
mejor a second isn't that in fact
evidence that someone isn't racist if
they real now if they're claiming they
have black friends and they don't and
obviously it's not evidence of anything
but if they really do have black friends
isn't that evidence that I mean it's at
least an indication that they probably
aren't racist because if you're racist
against a particular race you're not
gonna be friends with people in that
race it just seems like that's part of
the whole racism thing I don't know to
me it seems like a good solid piece of
evidence in somebody's favor but you
know that's not evidence because there
can there's just no if you are accused
of being racist you're not allowed to
present any evidence to clear you of the
charge you're just racist that's all
doesn't matter you've black friends
doesn't matter you a married to a black
person you have black family members it
doesn't matter you're racist doesn't
matter whatever you say doesn't matter
you're still racist so okay
there's that last question is it true
that our founders were racist is it true
that they supported slavery is it true
that they were bigots and sexist by our
modern standards well the answer to
those questions finally is yes okay that
is true that is all certainly true but
and don't take this the wrong way but
it's what what's your point
see this is why this conversation if
your point is simply to observe that
fact and say well that's wrong this
should have been racist okay
yeah I agree they shouldn't have been
but this conversation is so pointless
and fruitless this this sort of moral
relitigate of the past where we go back
and we observe these sins and and
foibles of our ancestors I think that
probably regardless that would be a
fruitless endeavor a pointless endeavor
I'm not really sure what the point could
possibly be but it's even more fruitless
and pointless because we are so
determined to relitigate the past
through a very narrow lens a lens that
pretends that these white racists
existed in a vacuum a lens that looks
not at the historical context not at the
you know the whole picture but just
focuses in on on white people and
pretends that there was something unique
and especially terrible about their
racism but if we were to widen the scope
a bit we would see that everyone
everywhere in the world in every country
was a racist and a sexist by our
standards today if you go back 200 years
or earlier so anyway any time up to 200
years ago you will find that every
country on the planet is filled with
tribalistic bigots by our standards some
countries still are now does
that excuse bigotry does that fact
excuse the individual bigotry of any
particular person who lived back then uh
no doesn't excuse it does it I'm
blanking on the word that I want here
mitigate there we go
does it mitigate to some extent their
own personal moral guilt for being
racist yes it does and this is a concept
I think people struggle with there's a
difference between the objective moral
you know quality of something and the
moral guilt of the person who engages in
that activity or or has that thought or
whatever it is so racism has always been
wrong all throughout history it's always
been just as wrong as it is now it's
just it's just wrong period right
however a racist two hundred years ago
or five hundred years ago probably does
not have the same moral guilt for that
racism as a racist today and the reason
it is that yeah if it just it's it's a
taken for granted now we may look at it
today and we say well it should be
obvious to you that you shouldn't be
racist that should be obvious it's
obvious to us well maybe it should have
been but it wasn't it's very clear that
for thousands of years of human history
it was not obvious that racism was wrong
because almost everybody was and if for
a long time it wasn't even questioned
the idea that all people in the world
are equal no matter what they look like
no matter what language they speak that
is a very modern concept they just
didn't occur to people for thousands of
years it just didn't occur to them so we
could say although I had should have but
it didn't it just didn't to anybody and
so we are left with the choice between
condemning everybody in history pretty
much as as just utterly bigoted horrible
worthless scumbags
or we can start to look at them in
historical context understand that they
had some blinds but some serious blind
spots try to understand those blind
spots why they had those blah
spots and and kind of leave it there and
then we can try to you know rather than
staying focused on that we could say
well what are our blood it seems though
as though people in every era have moral
blind spots just immoral things that
they take for granted we know for our
ancestors that moral blind spot was
racism and for a long time slavery -
well maybe we should look I think well
what are our blind spots do we really
have none or is it possible that there
are things that we take for granted that
are actually horrible I think maybe that
would be a more worthwhile endeavor all
right
speaking of racism or alleged racism
alexandria kzo cortez just essentially
called Nancy Pelosi a racist and this is
incredible she was interviewed by the
Washington Post and this is what she
said she said I'm talking about Nancy
Pelosi and the comments that Nancy
Pelosi has been making about her
supposedly she said when these comments
first started I kind of thought that she
was keeping the progressive flank at
more of an arm's distance in order to
protect more moderate members which I
understood but the persistent singling
out it got to a point where it was just
outright disrespectful it's explicit
singling out of newly elected women of
color she just accused Nancy Pelosi of
singling out women of color now is there
any evidence at all that Nancy Pelosi is
singling out women of color is there any
reason to believe that Nancy Pelosi has
an issue with aoc because of her color
and not because of the fact of her
harebrained policy ideas and her general
attention-seeking behavior no obviously
not and I understand the Conservatives
who laugh about this and say hey let him
leap their own and their even
conservative kind of encourage it and
try to oh yeah a Nancy Pelosi she is a
racist you're right about that
try to try to keep the internal strife
going I understand the strategy there
it's a smart strategy but I just I hate
this race-baiting garbage so much that I
have to take Nancy
seaside the race-baiting thing III
really just despise it because you know
there there are enough real problems in
the world and there's enough real
bigotry still III what we're talking
about a few minutes ago I don't mean to
suggest there's no bigotry left in the
world there's plenty of plenty of it
still left especially in other countries
where you know people who are in ethnic
minorities can be killed and stoned to
death and and so on but so there's
there's so much of it really out there
that to try to invent it for your own
purposes to try to exploit it you're
exploiting racism and III just detest
that someone's I find it so morally
abominable these people who have made
racism into a game into a tool for them
to use into a hammer they can beat over
the heads of their opponents and and do
it you know sort of indiscriminately or
just I mean with with aoc it's just
anyone that opposes her is a racist of a
sexist don't matter who even if it's
Nancy Pelosi it's racism doesn't matter
whatever it is and it's also it's so
intellectually cowardly there's so much
intellectual cowardice in Alexandria kzo
Cortez she is such a coward she refuses
to engage with anyone in an honest way
she refuses to engage any argument
honestly
instead it's Jeff
if you oppose her you're a sexist and
racist period I really can't stand that
so yeah you know what I actually have to
take Nancy Pelosi aside in this which is
a very bizarre sensation and I don't
like it okay let's see a couple other
things are let's see are you ready to
cringe I hope you're ready to cringe
because I have a very cringy thing to
show you watch this video what do you
what do you deserve everything you
deserve this okay so that's Megan
Rapinoe or rap you know I actually I
think I've been saying her name wrong
this whole time wide never heard of her
until you know a few weeks ago and now I
find her to be one of the most
insufferable people on the planet
because of videos like that
holding the trophies like I deserve this
she even said it in an annoying annoying
way I mean just the statement itself
I deserve this is annoying but she even
said it in a way that's extra annoying
now a lot of people have said that the
criticism of rapido rapido rapido is a
Rapinoe I think is Rapinoe is the
criticism is unfair and you know
male-male athletes never get criticized
this way and so on well first of all
male athletes get criticized all the
time
it's a very common occurrence constantly
criticized especially male athletes who
are perceived whether rightly or wrongly
for as being egotistical attention
seeking sorts of people you know those
kinds of ass those sorts of people in
general no matter what they do for a
living are going to be criticized
traditionally so that's the first thing
second male athletes don't usually do
some of the stuff that rap you know is
out there doing like hoisting the trophy
that you just won as a team and shouting
I deserve this I think most male
athletes have the concept of teamwork
just hammered into their heads from a
very young age so almost reflexively
when they're interviewed or when they
achieve something they're they're almost
always gonna bring it back to the team
but that's not about me it's about the
team whatever's good for the team the
team did this the team do that which is
good it's good it's a good thing it's
one of the great things about team
sports for kids is that it has this
humbling effect so if Tom Brady ever
hoisted up the Lombardi Trophy and
shouted I deserve this he would be
roasted for that by everyone and there
would be no one defending it but I think
as Tom Brady even though I think he is a
narcissist and maybe with good reason
considering is the greatest quarterback
in the history of the league and he has
and he's won you know approximately 65
Super Bowls but if he were to ever hoist
the Lombardi Trophy and say I deserve he
would be roasted by everyone rightfully
so but he wouldn't do that whether or
not he would like to do that or he has
those thoughts I don't know but he would
never actually do that when he hoist the
Lombardi Trophy which he's done several
times
he's always about the team he's talking
about the team but again if any male
athlete were ever to do something like
that they would be criticized by every
in fact it's oh this is where female
athletes have the privilege because a
female athlete does that and yes she's
gonna be criticized by some people like
myself who are consistent because I
would criticize anyone who did that male
or female but then she's also going to
have a chorus of defenders that the male
athlete won't have for the male athlete
no one's gonna defend them everyone's
gonna say oh come on man that's
disgusting
it wasn't just you was your team okay
what do you mean you deserve this your
team deserves it what is this I stuff
there is no I in team right but there is
a me okay that's what we haven't but
with female athletes there's going to be
that chorus the feminist who'd say in
fact I saw that video online yesterday
with a caption from someone saying I
forget what these exact words they use
but they said this is empowering it's a
it's basically making it about
empowerment I don't remember the exact
words I use but they were saying that
this is empowering for women it's a
declaration of female strength and so on
and that's just
again that's that is not something you
would ever hear for a male as if a male
athlete acts like an insufferable
blowhard narcissistic attention seeking
jerk
nobody is gonna say oh it's male
empowerment no one is gonna say that
it's it's only women who can partially
get away with being jerks on the basis
of its female empowerment they're the
old women are the only ones sorry if
you're a woman you're the only one who
could potentially dress up your jerky
behavior as empowerment men can't do
that they're not gonna get away with it
nor should they meanwhile though as a
nice palate cleanser so that was kind of
sports at its worst and let's look at it
at its best this is a video of a nun and
I unidentified hockey coach talking to
his players and his message while
colorful is I think truly good and
empowering watch this hey guys listen up
for a second first date can put
something really important okay we're
not women soccer
we're not the NFL if there's anybody
here that's going to be disrespectful to
either the American or the Canadian
national anthem grab your gear and get
the out now because you'll never see the
ice in this arena we don't have that
problem in hockey we're better than that
but there was no sense in wasting
anybody's time attention what's gonna
happen I don't believe it what happened
here for the for the most patriotic
sport that they have out there so just
keep that in mind thank you so that's
that's good stuff and that I mean that
reminds me of I didn't play hockey but
that reminds me of some of the coaches I
had growing up just I mean everything
the way he looks so the way he speaks
the cussing and I mean it just it's part
of the coach it's part of the male coach
thing and and the message which is hey
you know this isn't about you don't go
out there trying to disrespect the
country trying to make it about yourself
is we're not doing that here just that
kind of really Frank getting down to it
if you know
I could get the F out that kind of stuff
I really think that the boys especially
especially teenage boys need a voice
like that in their life and hopefully
they have it at home hopefully they have
a father who's you know even if he
doesn't drop the f-bomb he's still gonna
say still gonna have a message similar
to that okay you know you're not doing
that here cut it I cut out the crap it's
not happening here you need I think
children need it boys especially need
that but unfortunately there are a lot
of boys growing up in this country who
don't have that who don't have that kind
of disciplined take no crap male voice
and guidance in their home and that's
where sports even more become important
and that's why I think coaches do such
an important thing because they can they
provide something to a lot of these boys
that they aren't getting anywhere else
and that they need I mean you just you
need someone in your life as a kid to
say cut it out so I think that was that
was great
good stuff well done coach well done I
wanted to talk about one other thing
here before we get to emails yeah I
guess we'll talk about this it would be
easier to discuss if I played the video
for you but I'm not gonna do that
because it would seem hypocritical for
me to play it so I'll just describe it
there's a vibe maybe you've seen it
there's a viral video which went viral I
think yesterday millions of views
showing a man in a bagel shop I think in
New York I'm not sure we're probably New
York having a complete meltdown there's
no context provided the video cuts on
and he's screaming at pretty much
everyone in the establishment customers
employees and he's screaming screams at
some women in the store at one point and
starts talking about all the women on
dating sites who make fun of him and
reject him and then he yells at some
guys who are standing there one of the
guys proceeds to essentially tackle the
guy knock him on his butt and then I
think after that in a second video he's
screaming at the employees he's still
talking about women
on the dating site to reject him and the
guy is very short which is important
context to understand the video he's a
very sure looks like he's I don't know
five foot two or somebody's very short
guy very short for a grown man and he
says that women on the dating sites make
fun of him for being short and anyway
he's he's having a total meltdown
breakdown acting like a jerk to
everybody in the store well this was
secretly filmed of course and put online
and and now the guy has been humiliated
across the country along with being
humiliated at the store when he was
humiliating himself millions of people
now have taken part in the public
shaming and many have left comments
adding additional scorn and mockery and
talking about how short he is and and
and and everything else now first of all
obviously his behavior is unacceptable
if you saw the video you know I mean
it's unacceptable behavior wrong
atrocious behavior he deserved to get
his butt kicked in the moment I believe
he had that coming
nothing can can justify the way he was
acting and if you start mouthing off to
the wrong person in public you might get
knocked on your butt and I am I'm an
advocate of that I'm fine with that I
mean I I think that's the way it should
work in society they're just you know
sometimes it's like if you can't go
around just screaming at anyone acting
like a jerk to anyone you want if you
choose the wrong person he's gonna knock
you on your butt alright but here's my
thing did this incident really need to
be broadcast to the entire world did his
mental breakdown need to become an
episode of reality TV for us all to
watch and gawk at was the butt-kicking
in the moment enough or did he really
need massive public shaming on top of it
is the public shaming proportionate to
the infraction when I watched this video
honestly I my first reaction was I felt
bad for the guy I'm not saying that this
is because I'm so compassionate and I'm
so much better than you if you watched
it and laughed
look I've watched videos like that
plenty of times in the past and probably
laughed and even shared it myself and
taken part in the gawking festival
but on yeah I'm trying to get away from
that I think we should all try to get
away from that and when it came to this
video my first reaction was I just felt
bad for the guy
even though there's no excuse for his
behavior even though he was acting like
a jerk it seemed obvious to me that this
was is a lonely sad broken man
for him to be shouting about being
rejected on dating sites that may seem
funny to us but it seems clear that yeah
this is a guy who's I mean in his I
don't know 40s or 50s still alone
probably has been rejected by women his
whole life because he's very short it is
difficult for guys who are really short
sometimes to find you know to find a
woman women a lot of times don't want to
be with the guy it's a lot shorter than
them you know if you if you don't suffer
from that problem can I you know I don't
six-foot I say six foot one that's what
I say affair that smites unofficial I'm
officially six foot one I think really
six foot but anyway so I don't you know
I don't have that that's not a
particular problem that I have but it is
you know if it can be an issue for some
guys and if it leads to you being alone
for forty years it's a pretty serious
freakin issue right and so it seems like
this guy was at the end of his rope the
rope snapped and he essentially had a
psychotic breakdown we have no idea what
prompted or what led to it and that's
another problem I have with these with
these out of context videos again not
that any context could make that
behavior right but we don't even know
like what what were they was someone in
there needling this guy and trying to
get him rally up I don't know we don't
know maybe not maybe he just ran and
started shouting for nobody we have no
idea that that part is it shown either
way he's having a breakdown seems to me
a breakdown partially from a life of
disappointment and loneliness it seems
so is it really funny I mean can we not
should we be laughing at that I just
should we be laughing at broken troubled
people what does that say about us if
you say oh yeah it's hilarious
well what does that say about you though
and you think it says anything good
about you this is one of the reasons why
remember that video of the quote-unquote
trans the quote-unquote trans woman in
the I think it was a Gamestop really a
biological man in the game stop shouting
you know because he was addressed as as
sir and he said he'll call me ma'am I'm
sure you've seen that that he or at
least heard about it now I I believe I
never played that video on this show and
the reason I didn't play it is because
it's a similar sort of thing now you
know how I feel about the transgender
thing you know I think that if you're a
man you're a man so this guy's a man
period but it's pretty clear to me that
this was a very troubled person who was
having a breakdown in public a meltdown
and it's not funny to me I don't really
think that's funny this is real life
this is a real troubled person having a
meltdown living a life that clearly is
filled with misery and despair for them
and confusion I don't know I don't I
guess I guess I just still see the humor
honestly in it I have in the past I said
I'm not this is not a holier than now I
I have in the past seen the humor and
some of these kinds of things I think we
all have but what I'm saying is maybe we
should all together try to pull back
from this and realize that what we're
seeing on the Internet these are real
people this is not this isn't actually
reality TV reality TV is fake these are
most of the time these are actually just
actors pretending so you want to laugh
at them fine go ahead I mean that's what
they're there for and they signed up for
it literally and they enjoy obviously
being spectacles but these people that
just end up their viral videos and
everything you know they even if they're
having meltdowns in public they weren't
looking to be celebrities or be stars
they weren't looking for their 15
minutes of fame and I always think what
if and I'm sure this has already
happened
and we wouldn't necessarily know about
it but one of these days what if we find
out one of these days that
one of these people who had their
meltdown filmed for our amusement then
proceeded to kill themselves he's it R
is it far-fetched to think that that
could happen and maybe has happened not
at all and your is someone who's already
troubled already feeling you know
persecuted whether rightly or wrongly
and then you add on top of that the
scorn and mockery of millions of people
literally now if you've never
experienced scorn and mockery from
millions of people even if it is just on
the internet that doesn't matter these
are still people that are saying this
about you if you've never experienced
that level of mockery it's going maybe
it's hard to understand that it's a very
overwhelming thing even for a even for a
mentally stable person but if you're
unstable if you're having an episode of
some kind and then you add on top of I
mean it's not hard to see how we could
someone could be driven to suicide are
we gonna say then that it was still
worth it for the laugh or oh he had it
coming to him I you know and I'm not
look I'm not taking an issue in
principle with public shaming I have I
have I'm on the record as an advocate of
public shaming in principle that doesn't
mean that every person is should be
public [ __ ] publicly shamed I'm just
saying that public shaming can be
inappropriate response sometimes I don't
think that public shaming of someone who
has a mental breakdown for the purposes
of our amusement
you know if it's public shaming so that
we can amuse ourselves at the expense of
someone who's troubled and having a
break up
that's bad public shaming that is not
good now if we're talking about remember
that video a few months ago of the groan
of the man who who kicked an elderly
woman in the face while she was sitting
on the subway and that video went out
there and I put it on the show and and
that's the fact that the video went
viral is part of the reason why this guy
eventually was apprehended now that's
good public shaming ok that's someone
who's dangerous who committed a violent
crime who did something that is so
terrifically horrible that that it just
the punishment fits the crime
so it should be public shaming get this
guy's face out there everywhere
everyone knows that this guy's an
elderly abusing scumbag and then put him
in jail I think that's totally the
punishment fits the crime there but in
this case what's the crime is the guy
was a jerk at a bagel shop the
punishment of massive public shaming I
don't think it fits all right let's go
to very quickly we'll get to a couple of
you meals here this is from Matt well
show a gmail commas email address this
is from Joe says hello Matt when you are
dictator of the universe which
temperature will you mandate every
building to be set at give a winter
attempt at a summer tamp I will abide by
these tabs in preparation for your
pending rule also I'm so glad that
feminists have brought this subject up
because it needs to be addressed there
are many men out there who are victims
of females and their affinity to warm
temperatures I am a victim Matt and now
I must become an sjw for the victims of
temperature abuse I have temperature
abuse I like that
I'm surprised feathers haven't come up
with that term maybe they have I am a
socialist in only one surgery I'm a
submit that subject is room temperature
the room the woman the women who have
somehow tricked men into forfeiting the
room temperature need to be forced by
the government to distribute a few
degrees to the fellas maybe somewhere in
the mid 70s will be enough for the
fellows to survive the summer we live in
Arizona my wife purse prefers 78 to 80
degrees it's excruciating please help
your wife prefers it to be seven inside
look Joe I would never advocate divorce
but no I'm kidding of course it's a joke
all right but but your wife needs to I
mean it's 80 degrees that's that's crazy
this I mean maybe public shaming her
maybe you should publicly shame your
wife for this one this one died this
said that this punishment does fit the
crime 80 degrees inside is crazy I mean
we are we're civilized people here okay
we live in modern civilization
you don't live you don't need to live in
80 degree temperatures inside you want
80 degrees inside go to a sauna okay
your living room is not supposed to be a
sauna Joe's wife
you're gonna kill
man he is going to literally melt into a
puddle how dare you
as for the appropriate temperature well
I'm glad you asked that question of
course I do have a very specific demands
as far as that goes
so the appropriate temperature inside in
the summer is 68 degrees period that's
the appropriate you want to go down to
66 or 67 I will allow it you want to go
up to 70 I might allow it maybe if you
have a lot of fans in there but 68 is
the ideal that's where it should be said
68 as for the summer
I mean the winter inside you know 70 to
71
I wouldn't go above that so really
you're in that 68 to 70 range regardless
that's just what temperature should be
inside all the time but thanks for the
email this is from James says hi Matt I
am a fourth year medical student in the
middle of my psychiatry clerkship and I
just wanted to hop in briefly on the
discussion about psychiatric disorders
you asked why people get upset when you
question legitimacy and medical
significance of psychiatric disorders
the reason is because psychiatry is the
only field of medicine where we face
constant accusations of inappropriate
medicalization because of disease
symptoms that occur on a continuum of
normal experience a perfect example of
this is when people resist viewing
psychiatric conditions as disabling
disorders because we all feel anxious
sometimes and we all get distracted many
common 9 psych at psychiatric conditions
such as type 2 diabetes asthma
hypertension and obesity exist on a
spectrum of normality and every field
uses somewhat arbitrary guidelines to
distinguish between normal and abnormal
the reason we use a hemoglobin a1c level
of 6.5% to diagnose type 2 diabetes is
simply because the American Diabetes
Association decided that six point five
percent is the point where it's severe
enough to call it the call of disease up
until recently hypertension was defined
as a blood pressure greater than 140
over 90 two years ago the American Heart
Association changed our guidelines and
now anything higher than 130 over 80 is
called hypertension these kinds of
conditions that exist on spectra are
increasingly becoming the norm across
all of medicine as a result of Western
lifestyles leading to chronic disease
and yet the lay press constantly paints
continuum disorders as something unique
to psychiatry we have a growing body of
research clearly delineate delineating
ADHD and major depression as distinct
syndromes and the American Psychiatric
Association establishes thresholds for
diseases just like every other
professional organization does I've
never heard any conservative medical
traditionalists question whether or not
type 2 diabetes is a real disease I
never hear any anti medicine groups ask
if doctors are over diagnosing
hypertension so that the pharmaceutical
industry can make money putting everyone
on AC AC II inhibitors this kind of
skepticism and conspiracist conspiracism
seems to be almost exclusively reserved
for the fields of psychiatry and it gets
very tiresome thanks for reading ok I
wish I'd save that email for tomorrow
because I don't have a lot of time and
there's a lot there to address maybe
I'll get back to it tomorrow but I will
say first of all just for the record I
think that all fields of medicine are
subject to this criticism of
overdiagnosis over prescribing and I
think for a good reason you know I think
that many things are over diagnosed and
and there is a problem with people being
put on prescription drugs too readily
and that's why we have a nation of
prescription drug addicts I mean
prescription drug addiction is a huge
problem as I'm sure you're aware and
many of those drugs are you know
psychiatric drugs but not all of them I
mean think about painkillers now the
medical community why has I talked about
this on the show I think that I you know
I tore my Achilles go to the doctor with
a torn Achilles my calf muscle feels it
gets on fire it's most painful thing
I've ever experienced and and at no
point while I had the torn Achilles was
I ever prescribed painkillers they said
just take Tylenol
I was given prescription narcotics for
you know like five days worth after my
surgery I only used it for two days
because I really don't like that stuff
point is why were they being so tight
fisted with the prescription narcotics
and that's because it had become a huge
problem with people getting addicted to
this stuff the medical community had
come under fire for it rightly so and so
they pulled back so your claim that this
is exclusive to psychiatry I think is
not
true second thing you know ADHD let's
just focus on that for a moment you uh I
don't think you've really addressed my
point on just ADHD for a second here
my point is yeah ADH exists that is
people who have struggled struggled to
pay attention and are hyperactive now I
think the term attention deficit is kind
of strange because that that seems to
suggest that there is some ideal amount
of attention that you're supposed to be
able to give and if you can't give that
amount then you have a deficiency in
attention it's just to talk about a
deficiency inattention is a very weird
concept to me and again it is arbitrary
it seems well regardless okay not to
split hairs there are obviously people
who struggle to pay attention raise my
hand for that and struggle to sit still
raise my hand for that one and struggle
to you know keep their thoughts on one
track and their thoughts tend to go in a
million directions at once I raise my
hand for that too so I'm I'm guilty on
all three counts my point is that maybe
that's just how some people are maybe
that's just a personality type maybe
that is simply a type of person maybe
that is a way of being who is to say
that it's a disorder because when you
say it's a disorder what you're saying
is people shouldn't be that way and so
my question to you as the medical
student is how do you know people
shouldn't be that way especially when we
know that if you if you have quote ADHD
yeah it's difficult in school it's
different it's difficult if you work in
a cubicle and you sit at an office desk
for eight to nine hours a day but if you
do other things if you have a creative
job like like I do if you work outside
if you're more hands-on then it becomes
actually a benefit it's it's a it's an
asset for me with the job that I do I've
got to think of you know a million
different topics a day and I'm right
doing the show and I'm you know
constantly in my head for me to have
this condition while it made me feel
totally deficient and crazy when I was
in public school now it makes me feel
like okay I need to be this way in order
to do this it may seem like an easy job
in some ways it is that some some ways
it's not even a job at all but actually
to think of you know to come up with
commentary for several different topics
every single day and then deliver it in
two different forms writing and speaking
you know there are some there are some
challenges with that okay and so I find
that having my mind work the way it does
while again it made it very difficult in
math class it actually works well here
so given that fact my question again to
you is who are you to say it's a
disorder who are you to say I'm not
supposed to be this way maybe this is
just how I am I think with physical
diseases it's a little bit easier to say
well yeah people aren't supposed to be
the way with something like diabetes as
you know a diabetic if they don't get
that treated they could die so that's
pretty good indication that you're not
supposed to be that way and so you need
to get that treated ADHD is not gonna
kill you it's not gonna make your brain
deteriorate so I'm gonna give you cancer
you know it J won't it's just it just
makes it it makes it hard in some
contexts but then it also helps in other
contexts so for the third time and
really for the millionth time I say
maybe it's just how I am
maybe this is a valid personality type
that's that is my assertion and I think
you need to come up with some kind of
evidence that it is not a valid
personality type that it is in fact an
invalid disordered type that shouldn't
exist I think
to come up with evidence for that and
quoting the American Psychiatric
Association I don't think that's really
gonna help much because this is actually
in many ways a philosophical question
because the the underlying question is
now there's nothing really philosophical
about diabetes I take your point about
it exists on a spectrum okay good point
but it's not philosophic I don't think
there's really any philosophical
discussion about whether or not diabetes
is a disease there is a philosophical
discussion with something like ADHD
because the philosophical question is
how should a person be it's a very
deeply philosophical question actually
and when you say well a person shouldn't
be like that you are making a profoundly
philosophical claim that I happen to
disagree with all right and as I said
yesterday there are you know there are
other men mental conditions like you
know schizophrenia where someone is
hallucinating or
has no grip on reality I think it's
clear to me there that people shouldn't
be that way because that just you you in
that case you cannot really function at
all as a human person at all in any
context so you know
you have a clear good case I think with
ADHD it is not nearly so clear-cut all
right we will leave it there thanks
everybody for watching Godspeed
president Trump posts a social-media
summit at the White House today to
combat big tech censorship meanwhile
star democrat congresswoman alexandria
Ocasio cortez calls nancy pelosi a
racist
we asked the important question as
politics ever been this fun check it out
on the Michael Nolt show